hello everyone I'm uh V vitalic buan I'm
the founder of aerium um also now
co-founder of zuu and what exactly is
zalu so zalu is um this uh kind of EX
popup City experiment uh 200 people from
a combination of different communities
basically trying to get people to live
together in this one small location in
Montenegro for two months both going to
original suu group has kept going and
it's definitely interested in organizing
more kinds of things of different
formats in the future also there have
been various spin-offs of it already the
kind of population of the uh Village
fluctuated from between 150 and like
probably something like 250 or so ranged
from 450 to 1,800 depending on like
whether any of the subsid sces applied
how tightly versus how Loosely did you
schedule each day yeah what we did is we
took the Brian Johnson blert menu um and
then we turned that into a uh um you
know like healthy breakfast that's just
open to all of the attendees for free it
became a meeting point there was public
goods week there was Z knowledge proofs
week there was Charter cities and
network states there were like hiking
and running clubs that just kind of
formed pretty autonomously there was a
group that started doing daily cold
plunges zalu is the seed of something
that could compete with Harvard in terms
of the the kinds of other things that
people want to do that are not just
traditional University things I mean one
is being this community incubator of
midd crypto and ZK and open source
technology so basically saying like hey
if you have a really cool open and
privacy preserving U thing then you know
we as a community can help use it and
debug it and improve it and really turn
it into something great and and kind of
help make it be part of a coherent
ecosystem another thing is just kind of
being a gathering point for people who
are actively involved in um milk
creating new of open and free
societies